So, let's discuss what types of benchmarks do we have
out there. We can have real applications. They are the
most representative of real application but they are also the
most difficult to set up on a new machine. So, for
example, if we are building a new computer system we
may not be able to run a full fledged operating system
there. And have all the, you know, graphics cards and
hard drives etc., etc., connected, so it may not be possible
to run, for example, a web browser, or a database
on this machine yet. Next, we can have application kernels,
we find the most time consuming part of an application,
usually a loop of some sort, and we isolate just
that loop, and say that this is what are we
going to use for testing performance of machines. That way, we
don't have to run a full blown application. All we
have to do is find a way to run just
the kernels on the new machine that
we're testing. But sometimes running a reasonable sized
kernel is still too difficult. For example, in
the early stages of prototyping a machine, when
we may not even have a compiler, for
example. So, the next class of benchmarks are
the so called synthetic benchmarks. They are usually
designed to behave similarly to some type of
a kernel. But to be much simpler to compile.
Pretty much they are kind of the abstract of
a kernel. And finally, we can compare machines not
based on how well they perform on some actual
code that they're running, but purely based on peak
performance. In theory, how many instructions per second should
this machine be able to execute. Usually, peak performance
is only good for marketing. Doesn't tell us very
much about the actual performance of the machine. Synthetic
benchmarks are usually very good for design studies of
potential new machines, but they're not very good for
actually reporting performance to others. So we can use
these just to see how well do we expect a design to behave so that we can choose
among multiple possible designs. Once we actually build the
machine, we can use, for example, kernels to test
the performance of a prototype, and finally
we should be using real applications if
we are comparing actual machines that we
are trying to, for example, sell to somebody.